is it okay for a woman to leave a man
if she's not happy
yeah yeah for sure yeah 100
is it okay for a woman to leave a man if
he's a bum and refuses to get a job
um
yeah it is okay but i wouldn't say
to do it more time
is it okay for a man to leave a woman if
she refuses to lose weight
oh i mean
i don't know it's all subjective really
but i would say
no no no yeah i'll say no i'd say no
i'll say no but it's okay for the woman
to leave the man if he refuses to get a
job
do you think that's a different yeah i
think it's different yeah for sure why
because i don't feel like men should
just be lazy and if you're and if a man
is lazy then i don't feel like a woman
should just stick around and stay well
you don't think that's a woman being
lazy if she refuses to go go to the gym
and work out true yeah yeah true 100 100
but i just feel like just different yeah
why isn't that weird though
it's like almost there's different
standards for men and for women
like like men don't get the benefit of
the doubt but women do almost
yeah yeah sometimes yeah that's how
society sees anyway to be fair yeah so
you think if you dated a girl and she
gained 100 pounds you'd stick it you'd
stick it with her personally i wouldn't
personally i wouldn't but
i mean respectfully i wouldn't but i
mean i don't know who would
okay so then it kind of changes your
answer right
a little bit okay okay okay so is it
okay for a woman to leave a man if she's
not happy
definitely
i think they just should
leave them anyway okay is it okay for a
woman to leave a man if he's a bum and
refuses to get a job
um
yeah sort of bad [ __ ] vibes i like that
is it okay for a man to leave a woman if
she won't lose weight
no that's fuckboy attitude don't like
that
uh why because isn't it kind of the same
thing like if a guy won't get it body
fascism and like western body standards
as well it's like yeah i don't know i
just yeah they wouldn't be my kind of
person if they did really i think it's
okay
yeah because like if you gain a hundred
pounds you don't look the same
like i didn't think of that yeah it's
true like if he's not attracted to you
anymore what's he supposed to do that's
true actually that's true actually um
i think the lab
do you change i'm not talking i think
it's just quite it means that yeah they
obviously aren't soul mates because if
you're a soul mate with someone you
should be able to love what's inside
them you know what i mean you don't
think love is conditional
um
i know i'm an artist so i've uh i look
at it slightly differently
i think like i think it's because you
just i go by my like feelings and i like
throwing myself in because james baldwin
said this quote he said um
you know like with love you know you're
going to get hurt but if you duck it you
die so i don't know so i'm a bit of a
romantic
regard
so you don't think like there are
certain are
who are you dating
um
just looking around are you looking
you're not okay okay you don't think
there's certain can like for example a
condition for for a condition a
condition for me is that like
a guy can't be a serial killer like
that's a condition you don't think
there's you don't think there's some
conditions
and i know that's extreme but i'm doing
it to like prove a point right see what
you mean yeah yeah no being is i don't
it's fun you can be like bonnie and
clyde and be serial killers together
that's kind of what i would that's my
idea or rob a bank rubber bank that's
like goals rob a bank of someone is it
okay for a woman to leave a man if she's
not happy yeah of course he's yeah 100
so then is it okay for a man to leave if
his wife won't lose weight
yeah
yeah well i don't [ __ ] yeah
what what is the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
uh oh probably uh gelter that's our time
yeah yeah about six months
i'm sorry sorry guys
what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested um
do you think that women flirt for
attention and not because they're
actually interested
um
yeah i'd say yeah
do you think that makes it confusing to
men in this like me too era
well it can be in it you know you never
know whether to just approach a woman
and talk to him or not you know where
the line is yeah i think
no means no obviously and that's it yeah
on a serious note yeah i've got two
girls you didn't mean seriously yeah
yeah yeah okay for a woman to leave a
man if she's not happy
yeah okay okay is it okay for a woman to
leave a man if he's a bum and won't get
a job no no no if you want okay
why
i don't know see if she loves him she
she doesn't care about her does she okay
so is it okay
is it is it okay for a man to leave if
his wife won't lose weight
no no no no do you think it's okay for a
woman to leave a man if she's not happy
i mean that's fair yeah if she shouldn't
feel like the guy then there's no reason
to feel like before
do you think it's okay for a woman to
leave if he's a bum and he can't get a
job or he won't get a job not can't
i mean i think you're on a lot if you're
in love that like surely you can support
your man to be supportive dreams i'm
giving time but
if she wants to leave then that's her
own problem
do you think it's okay for a man to
leave if his wife won't lose weight and
she doesn't think he's she's attractive
anymore
i mean me personally i think that's kind
of it's kind of working it but if that's
his opinion then he can go with his
opinion it's okay so is it okay for a
woman to leave a man if she's not happy
it's not good it's not good no no no
it's not good
because if you're not happy with the man
how you can't stay with the with with
him how
so she should leave if she's not happy
no no she shouldn't leave no no
okay should a woman leave a man if he
refuses to get a job like they're
married and he just won't work oh
i say if he don't
i want to work
she need to leave him okay so should a
man leave a woman
if she won't lose weight
what
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
maybe yeah yeah
i agree yeah yeah i think like if if
yeah yeah
okay for a woman to leave a man if she's
not happy and she has a family it
depends
it all depends on why she's not happy
nothing really she just isn't feeling it
so she she wants to leave it she's got a
family yeah and she wants to leave
i disagree okay do you think it's okay
for a woman to leave a man if he's a bum
and he won't get a job not that he can't
he won't refuses to work 100 get rid of
it okay then on that note do you think
it's okay for a man to leave if a woman
won't lose weight
yes
if she's a big big big lassie
you think he should leave get out of
there get out of there she's a big whale
yeah okay okay next question do you
think women want equality
yeah i think they should they want
equality yeah because it's only fair
isn't it so then why don't women well
then why don't women protest when men
don't get into bars for free and they do
when women don't get into bars for free
or men don't get into bars for free and
women do so why aren't there protests
for that
they should be
shouldn't they then doesn't that say
that women don't actually want equality
you've got me there
difference between a woman not being
interested and playing hard to get
um
it's a great question
um
i don't even know answer that i don't
even know what do you think women flirt
for attention yes definitely do you
think then do you think that makes it
confusing for men
it does because if
they sometimes flirt for drinks and they
get them and then
you know then they run then they run
yeah
okay is um
okay what who's wife material the best
cook and the worst head or the best head
and the worst cook best head and worst
cook but why
well
you can always order in
is it okay for a man to leave if a woman
won't lose weight
yeah yeah
um do you think women want equality
yes then why aren't there marches for
men to get into bars for free
and to get free drinks
i didn't understand that question so if
women want equality why aren't there
marches for women to get to for men to
get into bars for free like women do
and to get free drinks like women do i
have no idea
the next question okay is it okay for a
woman to leave a man if she's not happy
no
no
is it okay for a woman to leave a man if
he's a bum and he won't work
nah that's not acceptable you don't
think it's okay to leave no it's not
okay to leave really why
and not that's not fair okay do you
think it's okay for a man to leave
if a woman refuses to lose weight and
he's
yeah so it's okay for the woman to leave
or the man to leave if she gets fat but
if the man becomes a bum she can't leave
nah yeah that's pretty much right
okay
okay um okay what's the difference
between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested if she's playing hard to get
then
wait what what's the difference between
a woman playing hard to get and not
being interested
she's playing hard to get then she
should show at least a little bit of
interest whereas when she's not
interested she'll just literally say
you're a bum
do you think women flirt to get
attention yes do you think that makes it
confusing for men yes
okay thank you